never want to play your ps4 games on
your PC well your wish is soon to be
granted according to Sony worldwide
studios head honcho Shuhei Yoshida I'm
Lucy and welcome to this streamed
gamespot news update Sony's Remote Play
service which allows ps4 gameplay to be
strange to the PS Vita across a home
network basically a way to play fallout
when you on the toilet is set to expand
to PC and Mac Shuhei Yoshida confirmed
the plans in a message to fans on
Twitter stating that we are indeed
working on an official application for
pc / mac open-mouthed smiley face smiley
face aside there's no official info on
how the service is gonna work or when
it'll even come out but the announcement
does come days after a developer who's
going by the online handle twisted
announced an unofficial Remote Play app
for Windows but this stuff isn't really
new microsoft offers a similar console
to pc streaming service where an xbox
one can be mirrored on a Windows 10
device so will you be playing your ps4
via your PC how many screens is too many
screens let me know in the comments
below I'll come find me on Twitter at
Lucy James games for all the latest
anshu a yoshida's tweet keep it gamespot
you